fox news host tucker carlson
is again facing calls to resign
or for fox news to fire him and or for
boycott
for advertisers to boycott his program
after essentially
arguing that the great replacement
theory
sometimes known as the white replacement
theory
is real in the united states but it's
not racist
to suggest it now it's very difficult to
know where to start because there's so
much here
but maybe to set the stage i'll tell you
a little bit about
great replacement or or white
replacement theory
uh this is something that comes from
france
originally in modern times it's
become a favorite of white nationalists
and white supremacists
originally in france it was a theory
that
white french people were being
deliberately replaced by
non-european people including arabs
south asians africans and others
through a combination of importing
people
from those countries through immigration
combined
with white french people being
encouraged to have fewer babies are
having a lower birth rate
now it's just become a very in the u.s
when we talk about great replacement
theory or white replacement theory it's
a popular white nationalist white
supremacist idea
um and it not only is it generally
speaking white supremacist it's also
specifically anti-semitic in some of its
flavors you might remember back in
the charlottesville white supremacist
rally back in 2017
they were chanting among other things
jews will not replace us
that's what this is about that's a
reference to exactly this idea
so tucker carlson goes on and he's
interviewed i think it's by mark stein
and says democrats do want
to replace americans and they want
to dilute the population but it's not
racist
it's just true so let's just jump right
into the first clip
i'm laughing because this is one of
about 10 stories that i know you've
covered
where the government shows preference to
people who have shown
absolute contempt for our customs our
laws our system itself
and they're being treated better than
american citizens now i know
that the left and all the little
gatekeepers on twitter become
literally hysterical if you use the term
replacement if you suggest
the democratic party is trying to
replace the current
electorate the voters now casting
ballots with new people more obedient
voters from the third world
but they become hysterical because
that's that's what's happening actually
let's just say it that's
true so tucker as a good foe populist or
maybe better said as a right wing
populist he knows enough to avoid
saying this in the way that is overtly
racist he does it more subtly and with
code
when he talks about replacing american
voters with voters from the third world
he's talking about voters that are
mostly brown people or black people
that's
it he's using coded language so not only
is this straight up great replacement
stuff it's also
it's also nonsense and as i've said
before trying to win elections by
importing people who are slightly more
likely to vote for them
in seven to nine years when they get
citizenship if they get citizenship it's
a terrible strategy
think of the numbers and this is why you
know we very often react to the rhetoric
and we ignore the sort of factual or
empirical basis 75 million people voted
for donald trump
if naturalized immigrants vote for
democrat
60 40 because remember even though a lot
of people like tucker want you to
believe that all immigrants are very
left-wing the truth is
that um you know cubans and venezuelans
are not very left-wing
there are lots of uh asian immigrants
that are not left-wing
there are many eastern european
immigrants that are not left-wing anyway
let's imagine that naturalized
immigrants
by a 60 40 margin vote for democrats
that means that for every 500 000
immigrants that become citizens
that's only a hundred thousand vote
margin for democrats
when you compare that to population
growth when you compare that the people
who move between states
it's a drop in the bucket when you talk
about bringing people
in having them wait the five years
before they can request
citizenship and then the additional
period to go through that process
if this is how democrats are trying to
win it's a very stupid strategy
let's continue with the clip if look if
this was happening in your house if you
were in sixth grade for example and
without telling you your kid
your parents adopted a bunch of new
siblings
and gave them brand new bikes and let
them stay up later and help them with
their homework and gave them twice the
allowance
that they gave you you would say to your
siblings you know i think we're being
replaced by by kids that our parents
love more
and it'd be kind of hard to argue
against you because look at the evidence
so this matters on a bunch of different
levels but on the most basic level it's
a voting rights question
in a democracy one person equals one
vote if you
change the population you dilute the
political power of the people who live
there
so every time they import a new voter i
become
disenfranchised as a current voter now
by
that logic every time a new
american-born kid turns 18 tucker's vote
is also
worth slightly less every time an adult
dies tucker's vote is worth slightly
more this is just life this is inflows
outflows
it's not evidence of any kind of grand
you know grand replacement theory
let's look at just one more clip here so
i don't understand why you don't
understand this i mean everyone wants to
make a racial issue out of it oh the you
know white replacement there no no
this is a voting rights question i have
less political power because they're
importing a brand new electorate
why should i sit back and take that the
power that i have as an american
guaranteed that birth
is one man one vote and they're diluting
it no they're not allowed to do that
why are we putting up with this so this
is what happens when people
fall for populism in some ways in
rhetoric
people will watch tucker and they'll say
that there's a lot there that sounds
kind of like bernie sanders
there's very there's a similar language
that's being used there
they're for the people they're for the
middle class they criticize the elites
uh corporations sometimes i'm with the
little guy
but then tucker goes on a rant about
third world immigrants deluding his
voting power
uh black lives matter is going to take
your house immigrates make
immigrants make the country dirtier as
he said i don't know if it was six
months or a year ago
we covered it this is the guy that some
on the left are idolizing
saying tucker is out flanking the left
on some issues there's a contingent on
the left that has completely fallen for
this guy
it's incredible stuff and as you know
consequences
for tucker i imagine none that he's at
fox news
to do this type of stuff this is a
feature not a bug
and while he's dealt with some
advertiser boycotts
anybody hoping for some kind of
repercussions to this
do not hold your breath we'll have more
on this story
and others from today's show on the
david pakman show instagram page you can
find us at david pakman show
and if you want to see a very strange
hate mail that i got this morning
follow me on instagram david.pacman
you may not have known this but when you
see me sitting here on the show
i am often wearing shirts by a company
called teddy stratford i asked them to
be a sponsor
because they are by far my favorite
shirts that i own
with almost all other slim fit button up
shirts i've worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good but what makes teddy
stratford shirts unique is this patented
zipper that's hidden underneath the
buttons which actually prevents the
chest from looking weird and stretched
out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt in a specific
way
that makes your upper body look a lot
better it's just a much nicer and more
stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100 percent
egyptian cotton and flat felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout